oh my god it hurts you hey what's going
on everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today we're joined by
Chicago's own chance the rapper he's a
three-time Grammy Award winner and one
of the most exciting names in hip-hop
check out his debut studio album the big
day which released earlier this year and
you can see him on rhythm and flow a
music competition series airing on
Netflix now chance the rapper welcome to
the show yo what's up so many people
credit you with bringing back spicy
chicken nuggets so I take it you're
pretty good with the heat I'm actually
not a spicy like I don't like to like no
no that's not at all true I'm terrified
right now let's face the fear let's face
the fear chance okay
[Music]
which direction am I going in so I
definitely eat though we'll start at the
handle started the handle if you get
lost along the way that sauces are funny
because like this one has like a nuclear
bomb on its you know if like you're
working your way too far you're getting
to the sort of like the dicey zone okay
[Music]
so I want to start by talking about your
Netflix show rhythm and flow which is
this music competition series where you
alongside fellow judges TI and cardi B
try to find the next big rap superstar
watching the first four episodes so I
feel like maybe you're the Simon Cowell
yeah it does feel like that they kind of
put me in that position right I don't
know I think that's the edit cuz
everybody was be keeping it real it just
seems like like I was shutting [ __ ] down
I don't know and then in the Chicago
episode you guys shoot on location at
two places one the Harold Washington
library and then another Reggie's over
on State Street
what role did those two institutions
play and help him launch your career
well
Reggie's was where we we had a show that
we sold out and it was like the first
hip hop show to sell out at the spot
that didn't like to book Hip Hop shows
definitely not local Hip Hop shows and
we were like local local kuvira
fresh out of high school also this was
before any of us I really like blew up
or like anybody on the internet knew who
we were and then yeah and then the
library that just completely built me
like that was like my rhythm and flow
like I used to go to a hunk of mic there
and every it was I think it was every
Wednesday or every other Wednesday they
would have this big home for Mike where
like everybody would come through and do
their poetry or dance or stand up a rap
and there was a guy there named brother
Mike who used to just like pulling on
the side pulled me to the side and be
like
you know practice your rap so you can't
rap anymore I like stop you know
cursing so much you know do a new piece
I would come there and perform the same
pieces every week because I was
comfortable with them and stuff but yeah
it was just like he was a huge influence
on my life and a lot of artists most
artists that came up around my
generation from Chicago
[Music]
actually hate jalapeno as a flavor so
but you like Chicago so this one's like
a real I like just show fun doing
outside said to just like hurry up and
finish it if you keep it in your mouth
it's it gets hotter I like that you
traded notes with offset so when Shia
LaBeouf was on the show you push forward
this theory that your favorite comedians
are probably good freestylers because
it's the same skillset and ability to
ad-lib do you think that it might be
true the other way as well like do you
see a connection between rap and comedy
yeah the most stand-up comedians they do
like fill out the room and stuff but
they're more so like they have a piece
that they wrote themselves that they go
through and even if they ad-lib a little
bit it's like mostly their piece when
you're an actor it's like someone else
gives you words you interpret it and
then if you're lucky if the director
doesn't hate you
then you can ad-lib a little bit you
know what I mean but Shia LaBeouf is one
of the best freestylers of all time
swaye said he's the best freestyler in
hollywood yeah definitely
definitely in an active but I mean like
period like he's fire he could do that
you can put him together
that doesn't sound bad at all the
heartbeat pineapple Oh habanero
pineapple habanero catching that
habanero a little bit yeah habaneros
coming through so throughout your career
you've wrapped the Chicago White Sox
from throwing out opening pitches to
narrating pregame pump up videos - even
today rocking the Hat here on out once
this was the one I found Wow
do you have any insight to why White Sox
gear from the days of eazy-e and Ice
Cube to you and Kendrick Lamar why it
has such an esteem place in hip-hop uh I
don't know that's a good observation I
would say it's probably the colorway the
black and white over way over like ever
feeling you know connect it or accept it
in baseball I think it's more so a like
a rebranding of something that we find
to be cool well you know like jay-z he
puts his money and he puts his like
brand behind the nets to make that cool
oh you have like the Toronto Raptors and
Drake like what do you think a team has
to benefit by partnering with a mega
famous super fan you know it just makes
them cool obviously I feel like it's
also like about the city appeal you know
I I like the White Sox cuz they
represent the south side of Chicago to
me Drake has a whole voice the team is a
bunch of people's voices funneled
through to just be like hey where are
gear are like come to our game I mean
they just have a surgeon like fluidity
with the fact that they're actual people
and not just entities as go Cubs go a
Bop no go Cubs go why do I know that go
go why do I know that that's the Cubs
theme song yeah I guess it is about cuz
I don't even know how I know that melody
that you just put that song maybe it's
from that World Series who knows
[Music]
when is the big jump
it changes person-to-person over here so
you know it's it's in the it's in the
mouths of the beholder I suppose but
speak science to me back like right here
I would say is a significant jump I'm
like 5 to 6 into 7 and then just a like
a the size of the Grand Canyon its I'm
sort of jumped from someone to date and
we're on oh we're on force I thought we
were going to stillness alright so in
this instable ease clickbait ha take age
that we're living in the nuance
relationship between vans between
artists between critics it seems to be
more complicated than it's ever been so
with that in mind what I want to do is
hit you with some quotes from famous
musicians covering the topic and I'm
just curious if you think they're true
if you think that's false if you have
any sort of chance to wrap or take on it
ok yes this first one is from Knoll
Gallagher who actually said this on this
show fans they don't know what they
[ __ ] want no one wanted a Jimi
Hendrix before he came along no one
wanted Oasis till we came along no one
wanted the Sex Pistols they don't know
what they want until you give it to them
I feel like that's a hundred percent
jura and I feel like it is a brave
decision to be an artist even if you're
not famous especially if you're famous
but to be like hey I've made this myself
and put it out there for you to enjoy
and also judge I definitely feel like
people don't necessarily always know
what they want because there's a bunch
of songs that I didn't that I probably
heard tastes evolved and people change
yeah this is from jay-z at the 2009
American Music Awards men lie women line
numbers don't numbers lie I really like
numbers I sometimes just because it's
like
it's still like a representation of
something but not all the
characteristics of it because no no yeah
no I don't know do I disagree with him
or do I agree with them on hounds I
agree with that all right two more for
you this is from a since deleted tweet
from Liz Oh people who review albums and
don't make music themselves should be
unemployed
well that's oh really that's a strong
take on it I don't necessarily feel like
they should be unemployed but I do feel
her to a certain extent I feel like I
don't I don't think that that job
shouldn't exist I like they should be
unemployed I think it's just like maybe
there's just a different process to it I
feel like the idea of like being a
critic I need to listen to it find out
if it's good or not and then write up a
piece about it you know there's a
certain way that they systemically
ingest music it might not be the same
way that you know the regular consumer
might take that [ __ ] out you know well
set one more for you this is from Lady
gaga
I actually don't want a throne at all
because I don't view myself as a queen I
view myself as one of my fans yeah I can
see why somebody wouldn't want to be
considered someone that's being exalted
or like the finite top of something
that's kind of wack but yeah am ia fan
of myself definitely so yeah I [ __ ] we
got on that and I feel like totally
[Music]
habanero horseradish garden era
[Music]
it's a little bit of a jump here yeah
[Music]
well it was great doing this interview
all right chance we have recurrent
segments on our show called explain that
Graham where we do a deep dive on our
guest Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
show you the picture you just tell us
the bigger story does that sound good
yes all right first things first do you
remember what happened with the birth of
the bucket voice okay so I'm with Doug
McDermott and Jimmy Butler and this is
at a time when they all play for the
Bulls and the bucket boys are the bucket
yeah isn't Chicago we played the drums
and I don't know I was wasted and I was
like hey we're the bucket boys and they
was like yeah I was like take this
picture so you remember where it's
taking this is a Gabrielle union's
birthday party in Chicago like a few
years there you go Wow the caption here
is don't put ranch on my chicken ho yes
Skrillex I could definitely tell you
what's going on here so Skrillex sunny
great great guy
mazing dude this dude has like five
houses in LA he let me stay at the one
that had a studio in it and he came over
and he was like I got these chickens can
I put ranch on and I was like let me
take a picture of how ridiculous you
sound right now
scorpion for pepper sauce blend and it
says very hot at the bottom so should I
have put it in my body for TV I guess so
[Music]
[ __ ] that was an offset bike right
there
[Music]
approaching the ceiling a little bit huh
I'm a real [ __ ] man but that [ __ ] is
insane c'mere milk yeah yeah all yours
all yours so looking at your career in
public persona I think one of the more
complicated things to unpackage is the
way people react to you being a
Christian rapper at least putting faith
in the music that you make when you see
headlines like vais saying it's tough to
be a chance the rapper fan when you're
not a Christian what is your reaction to
that
maybe maybe that's true I don't know I'm
how to sail right now does that sound
like it makes sense though No
[ __ ] is obviously Kanye has been
generating Kanye levels of interest in
this Sunday service thing
what's your milk and ice cream hey let's
bring you the ice cream let's bring it
Leah what's your initial thought on that
kind of music sharing and how is it
different than like tearing down a
concert at United Center
[Music]
I guess slightly more important because
it's doing what we're supposed to do
which is shouting praise seeing Kanye
get all these people together reveal
these songs of worship that have been
around forever to people that may not
know them or it's an important thing
that I think it's supposed to be
happening right now it's dope that he's
doing it Dom
she's a lifesaver what's the word again
for the for the [ __ ] that they put in
there to make a hot
capsaicin conversation so this is
actually an extra creamy extra fat extra
sugar ice cream that I got you like
looked into the science a little bit
yeah you got to understand like this was
the dumbest [ __ ] I've ever done in my
life because I don't like hot [ __ ] and
I'm highly aware that I sweat where I
[ __ ] I read you guys our piece on it too
on the web yeah I'm impressed chance I'm
not no goofy dog
[Music]
could you just start to prepare a second
bowl yeah cuz I think Dom's on it Tom's
on it you're doing grass that was only
like the first that was the first like
officially hot [ __ ] right but look now
how far down the line we are you know we
are close to that finish line look at
all that's behind us just a couple in
front of us we're almost there word I
just want to point out I wasn't really
like an athlete in high school like a
lot of people that I know that do the
show or like they used to like they have
like this athletic drive to like beat
something I don't feel like I'm
necessarily winning by eating all of
them yeah I could at any point tap out
it would not feel bad about it I would
be fine
okay it would be fine what you all one
side well they dropped out over there
did you read that on some sort of yeah
so in 2015 your younger brother Taylor
Bennett actually did a first we feast
guide to dining after hours in Chicago
so now that we have you here we just
want to hit you with some of your little
brother's recommendations and I'm just
curious if you agree or not okay haha
psychological thing bring up my little
brother Oh we'll keep you in the game
yeah keep you in the game according to
Taylor the best pizza in Chicago is
Connie's pizza on 21st and Archer career
disagreement I highly agree with that
actually yes he is correct Giordano's or
Lou Malnati's
I'll go with lose hello it lose but
Giordano's is still fire ones got to go
Harold's Portillo's Al's Italian beef
house Diane beef out of here
where is the best three am drunk eat
spot in Chicago isn't cheesie's is that
is that the grilled cheese yes but I'm
not careful ready I didn't get mad but
the I think probably that strong food
spot have you ever been a Sully's over
on like north and Clybourn it's like a
black hogs pie that's the spot yeah they
have a like a these Sully sticks there
[Music]
No all right
look like I'm gonna take a 10 a 10 a 10
a bite that's fine I'm gonna keep it
pushing
chasin the bite with the ice cream smart
I think
[Music]
why does someone make that I think
specifically for this show you worked
with everyone from Kendrick Lamar to Lil
Wayne to Justin Bieber and Ed Sheeran
who has the most fascinating work
process in the studio Lil Wayne he just
stands on the corner behind you oh my
god it hurts you I wanna fight you I
understand I understand we're in this
together we're in this together but I
understand the impulse
Lil Wayne stands behind you and just
quiet he doesn't even really bother it
kind just looks around at a certain
point he taps an engineer he goes away
into another room and genera turns down
the music and goes on headphones with
the holidays fast approaching I'd be
remiss not to mention your 2016
Christmas album with Jeremiah which is
called Merry Christmas Lowell mama what
rap song would you put in the pantheon
with like jingle bell rock and all I
want for Christmas is you
whoa there's a song called held it down
by Chancellor a Pancham pie and it's up
today it's a pear stuck there I want to
go down in history as the negative quit
I feel I don't feel bad at all about
tapping out you know I think that if
anything chance has been hot you should
be proud of yourself
because you really pushed it because I
know my yeses and my nose right so I
could look at these last two pieces of
chicken sa no [ __ ]
oh it's so hot all right let's bring in
a new fresh napkin fresher napkin whoa
what can you tell the people about
chance the snapper and did you follow
that saga as it unfolded yes Chancellor
snapper has a blessing and disguise
because I was getting ready to drop my
album nose whoa I was in the studio
my wife was getting more and more
pregnant I have a lot of time to go do
radio interviews and stuff and then the
chance of snapper thing happened was
huge promo I don't know why this was
like global news everywhere in the
country they were talking about this
alligator in Chicago that what happened
alligator got stuck in a swamp yes
they're gonna swamp in a [ __ ] humble
Park hmm that's the story and someone
named it chance to snapper and now it's
like Emma knows everyone you know what I
think is like the most interesting
funniest part of that story is like they
had like Chicago's local Gator guy like
Gator Bob out there who is a misleading
around that look he was even one who got
it though know what they did is they
brought in some Gator expert from
Florida and in like three seconds he
like caught that thing and there was
like the weight of this city was on
Gator Bob to try to find get out the
water Bob we're calling in a real
professional all right xxx you're gonna
do it yeah
you know duty calls this is the last dab
we call it the last tab because it's
tradition to put a little extra on the
last wing you don't have to if you don't
want to yeah you're so right about that
I don't have to
since we're since you're actually in the
wings and I'm not is it cool if I
interview you a little bit if actually
some yeah that would be my existential
question sure sure sure I feel like it's
good content so first though mm-hmm okay
so if a tree falls in a forest no one's
there to hear it doesn't make a sound
no it does not make a sound where do you
fall you're correct that is the right
answer
[Music]
why why why not
you're amazing at this man you did a
great job today yeah thank you and I
just have one more for you yeah come on
why not because one thing that we
haven't touched yet is how you are so
unflappable independent but now that
you're distracted by some of the hottest
sauces and chicken wings we're gonna try
to sign you to hot ones records so I'll
just throw a couple deal points at okay
and then you you can maybe point a poke
a hole in whatever I'm offering okay
give each one one by one all right eight
album deal for you a sizable advance and
a generous 25% on royalties no but let
me let me negotiate against myself okay
okay let's go total 360 partnership deal
all right we want to go in on a hundred
million dollar advance 10-year deal
fifty-fifty on everything the albums the
tours the merch let's crush it bro
no all right all right listen listen you
might as well empty out my pockets here
okay okay you drive a hard bargain
chance but how about this okay 200
million over the 10 years we match that
okay with a donation to the Chicago
Public School System and we cure cancer
baby no Randy Randy I almost written
legal I almost had your ready to prepare
the paperwork but here we are but look
at you chance the rapper taken over the
sand no you always got a no one to say
no and you sir are an expert now there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
this camera this camera okay let the
people know what you have going on in
your life I'm gonna straight here sure
okay yo its chance the rapper I just had
my second baby not physically but in a
familial sense I had just dropped my
album the big day
my debut album is available everywhere
and I'm about to go on tour start in
January 15 in San Diego thank you I
appreciate know I appreciate you pushing
the bomb was cuz this one that's the
fire fire and this one I could tell this
was the one that you were like what am i
doing on the show yeah that was that was
like literally the moment cuz pass me
tell me about this forever obviously and
I'm like man I love the idea I think the
show's great me personally won't last on
that oh my god what is up what is up
spice Lords like and subscribe like and
subscribe first we feast first we feast
like and subscribe your knees up see
your unique New York
wah-wah-wah-wah like and subscribe
it's camera guy Billy here saying it's
good to be camera guy bill
you
[Music]